hello everybody and welcome to this
tutorial on a new opportunity to come
and work for the EU institutions
we have just published a competition to
select experts in the field of
intellectual property and as usual on
our website you will find this visual
giving you an overview of the different
steps to take to become a successful
candidate in this competition in this
tutorial I will walk you through these
different steps and tell you what the
details are of each phase
the eligibility criteria it is an 86th
grade competition meaning you need
either a bachelor degree in law
plus three years of experience in the
field of intellectual property
or a bachelor in other field than Law
plus five years of relevant experience
or a bachelor in an other field in Law
plus four years of experience and an
additional master or PhD in intellectual
property rights you will find this of
course Very detently explained in the
notice of competition which you find
also on the website where we have
published this competition
then there's also of course a language
Criterium you need to speak two
different EU languages your language one
can be any of the 24 and you must Master
it on level C1 and your left your
language two should be one of five
either English French German Italian or
Spanish because these five languages are
the languages used in the office dealing
with intellectual properties which is by
the by the way based in Alicante so a
nice destination and a nice place of
work if ever you are successful in this
competition your language too should be
at least at level B2
the selection procedure looks at this it
has roughly three stages if you like
first there's an application Phase then
there's a testing phase and then there's
of course the results phase
everybody who applies gets invited to a
single day of testing so in one day you
will sit the three tests listed here
reasoning skills feed the rater test and
the case study I will get into detail a
bit later in this tutorial
you will sit all these tests remotely so
you do not have to travel to a test
center to take these tests you can
simply sit them from your home computer
at your ease the third phase is then of
course the results uh phase so let's get
into detail
um in these three phases everything
starts with an application and in order
to apply you need to create an episode
account of course if you already have an
episode account you can use it to take
part in this competition or to apply for
it
if not you apply you you create an
account on our episode website
you can apply in any of the 24 languages
and you should do so before the 29th of
August noon Brussels time so you have
plenty of time to fill out your
application form
I said everybody who applies gets
invited to book a testing date and on
this day you will sit several tests we
start with testing your reasoning skills
we test your verbal numerical and
abstract reasoning skills in your
language one
you see the questions and duration the
scoring mentioned here
for the verbal reasoning test there is a
pass score of 10 out of 20 so you need
at least 10 out of 20. if you have more
very good if you do not have at least 10
out of 20 you are out of the opportunity
to be a successful candidate of course
for numerical and abstract reasoning
there is a combined passcore as you can
see you need 10 out of 20 combined for
these two tests
you can prepare for this uh reasoning
skills test by having a look to our
sample tests which you find on our
website you see the link here and you
find sample tests in all 24 languages
available to try and prepare you for
this test
the second test you will take is a field
related test so there we will assess
your knowledge in the field of
intellectual property you will take this
test in your second language and the
passcore is 15 out of 30 at least
the third test is a case study where we
will test your drafting skills in again
your second language the minimum pass
score being 5 out of 10.
now
to calculate the final score
for you to know if you are on the list
list of successors candidates or not
there is some higher mathematics
involved as you can see on this slide
but I will explain it to you
we take into account your score of the
field related test and the case studies
or not the reasoning skills test you
need to meet the pass score for the
reason skills test as long as you have
met that passcore you are still in the
running for a place on the reserve list
the field rated test and the case study
come into play when ranking you when it
comes to ranking you for determining the
list of successful candidates
the weight of the field rated test is 70
of the final score and the weight of the
case study score is 30 so in the last
column there you see that the final
score for the field rated test a is 70
of your score that you reached when
sitting the test
for the case study the final score B is
30 of your score obtained during the
case study test we multiply this score
by three why because the case study was
marked on 10 points and the feed rate
test was marked on 30 points so if we
first have to level this out in order to
be able to wait the scores correctly to
then reach a final score for your
results I hope that is clear it's all
explained again in the notice of
competition
so the ones with the highest scores are
the ones listed on this so-called
Reserve list or list of successful
candidates we are looking to select 200
successful candidates so again this is a
very big competition
the ones listed on this on this list are
then recruitable by the EU IPO which is
the EU intellectual property office as I
said based in Alicante
whenever they have vacancies available
they will scan the list invite the
people to a job interview and then if
your your job interview is successful
you can start working in the office
I hope this is clear if not anyhow
please do read the notice of competition
very carefully because everything is
very well explained in that document
and if you have more questions you can
always reach out to us through the web
form on our website my colleagues will
be very happy to answer all questions
available
I wish you all good luck with applying
and then taking part in the tests of
this competition and I hope you'll be
one of our future colleagues in the EU
thank you and see you next time